but i i have a question i'm sorry for
for kind of interjecting here but i'm so
curious whatever happened to the to the
cia declassification of the jfk
documents that donald trump
that donald trump
wanted to release said i can't control
myself i'm sorry tim i know we were on a
specific segment but i'm like i need to
know what was going on here because
donald trump's like i need to release
this we're releasing it to the people
that people demand to know and we're
going to give the people what they want
we're going to give them the information
unredacted from the jfk documents and
then the cia came in said no no no no no
not so quick there trump and then kind
of uh made trump stop
his his uh his the larger uh seeking of
the truth with with the jfk assassin
you're probably not gonna like my answer
on this but uh basically
uh i think under the trump
administration he did put out some more
of the jfk documents
what he didn't put out which i have
reviewed um
i think what what's out there is what
you need to know
are you saying without revealing any
classified information people would be
disappointed oh well it's true because
the government sometimes classifies
stuff that doesn't even need to be
classified uh so there's there's that as
well it's a misdirection it's about
confusing people yeah every time people
are always you know the sexiness of
classified information
you know sixty percent of classified
information that i've read or produced
in my career i'm like why is this
classified yeah
usually a lot of it is what's in the
mainstream
yeah uh but uh i i still don't think we
know the larger truth about jfk
personally that's just my own personal
perspective and my own personal opinion
but i was dying to know like why did
trump back down because it he did lose
that one publicly in the public eye
because he was like i'm gonna do this i
guarantee this to american people cia ci
cis cia said nope and donald trump was
like okay and and that was the story
yeah and that was the story of showing
me like okay what's really happening
here there there must be some kind of
power structure but that donald trump
can't be it can be
it can be something completely unrelated
that you don't realize like something in
a report overlaps with a report related
to cuba so they're just like we don't
want to get that one out there because
people could infer from this this was in
the 50s
like this we're talking about decades
is there any i mean other than
implicating maybe the bushes but but but
like
we're talking what implications would
there be right from the 50s let me just
give you an example of of in generally
speaking having run some of these
investigations the fbi
almost never closes some of its biggest
investigations some of them are 70 years
old yeah it's an ongoing investigation
the reason you keep it open is because
it allows you more wiggle room to work
in the future in the now and in the
future and so
you know like tim was saying like seven
years later like what does a have to do
with z from back then nothing but it's
just connected to the same investigation
there could be there could be there
could be one person involved in multiple
operations and still ongoing yes right
now from the
i'm not i'm not maybe i'm just saying
i'm not saying you're not true but i'm
saying the possibility of that is very
unlikely you could be right but
you know who knows so you're saying that
i'll make you a deal if if president
trump wins in 2024 we'll make you a
special government employee
i would you'll you'll review the
documents and you'll make the call i
would love for you i would like are you
going to work with trump in 2024
he goes in i go in
that is a verbal contract
uh that is that is legally bound by the
laws of the internet if adam schiff and
china are listening that was a joke
so one of the one of the funniest things
is uh when we all got sick the therapy
we got i guess it was also like 200
members of congress got the same
treatment
the funny thing about this uh we get
sick i call the doctor and the doctors
like take the stuff and i'm like okay
and then you know i was like i got
people who are sick and they're like we
think everybody should get the therapy
the monoclonal antibodies and then i
guess joe mentioned on his show
uh if this is true that like 200 members
of congress got similar and their family
members and their family members yeah
and i just thought it was really funny
when i was like hey luke isn't it funny
that you are getting the same treatment
as the illuminati
kind of caught me off guard there
but i did have a doctor's prescription
for uh ivermectin but that's another
story uh i shared a lot of those stories
on my uh own channel and my own
perspective but uh what am i supposed to
do when the doctor says i want you to
take this i actually said no to the
doctor at first and they were like you
have to and i'm like okay do i take don
lemon's word for it or do i you know uh
joe rogan
the covet origins the whole mandate all
that stuff is just unfortunately again
turned into
political football political theater
rather than what what happened where did
it come from we we have really good
intel on covet origins right again i was
back at od and i running running the ic
and part of our job is to brief the
president presidential daily briefing we
take the most sensitive intelligence we
walk into the oval we say hey mr
president x y and z he makes a decision
with his cabinet
he decided based on those briefings
we're going to shut down travel from
china he's a racist fast forward turns
out
the whole world issued shutdown uh
travel shutdowns and they're still
ongoing only just recently did the
canadian border and the the the uk to
the us right and the eu and so this is
just another example of the media
carrying the water leaking false
information from the deep state in the
government to perpetuate a fraud or just
make donald trump look bad and uh i got
to say this this is sort of related but
not really but i always i promised uh
the brothers that i serve with that i
would say this so
the vaccine mandate here's the thing
that takes me off the most okay we did
the afghan withdrawal we did it the
right way biden comes in and wrecks the
thing right 13 service members die
bringing them back but we fly 125 000
refugees back here don't vet him nobody
gets a kova test nobody gets a coveted
mandate vaccine southern border illegal
immigrants getting stopped at the border
of being allowed to come in none of them
are tested for covet or given a covet
vaccine mandate but my brothers in the
special forces community have to decide
about taking a covert vaccine mandate or
taking a knee for america and that i
think is the worst worst crime that's
being committed right now especially
with people who can't take it and
doctors are saying no there's a
re-ticket i mean aaron rodgers a
professional football player was talking
about how he has allergies that prevents
him from taking this and that's on the
cdc's website this is the crazy thing
the website says here's the ingredients
you can read them for yourself if you
have allergies to them you should not
take this vaccine and aaron rodgers was
like oh yeah two of those ingredients i
have an allergy to nbc news released a a
great article surprisingly i'm surprised
that they i can't believe i'm saying
this myself about about the monocle
antibody treatments showing how it lasts
over eight months and and has uh gives
people a lot of protection and prevents
a lot of serious cases from developing
the nba ruled if you're in the nba you
took the johnson and johnson shot two
months after taking it you need another
booster shot
pfizer moderna you need it every six
months to be compliant with their
vaccine passports which of course
they're implementing
in professional sports but they already
implemented in israel israel people have
been forced to take a third invasive
medical procedure uh to be compliant
with being able to live in a society i
mean that's just absolutely here's the
scary thing about all of it right i'll
give you
we created the uh coveted vaccines in
like seven months polio vaccines took
seven years
seven years right and i'm not saying you
shouldn't have done it right it should
be an option for those who want to take
it but here's the other thing we don't
know the long-term effects of this at
all nobody's been tested beyond a year
and a half
this is in the fda insert
on the community vaccine it says
long-term trials are currently underway
so you got to be careful because
youtube's like you know they'll they
come after you if you say basic facts
like crowder's gotten hit on youtube
several times for just citing the cdc
but you know what what am i supposed to
do not say these things like it's it's
the truth
the fda literally said it but the
problem that americans are now facing or
have been facing is because thanks to
the likes of fouching everything they
don't know what to trust they don't know
if i can trust the nih they don't know
if i can trust the cdc or the fda
because every time this guy goes to the
podium and says one thing in another
month he's saying the exact opposite
why why didn't trump fire fouchy
i mean i wish he had fired a lot of
other people but i i throw fouch sure
who's top on your list like millie
millie is definitely up there you know
back in comey we got rid of him so that
was good but like rod rosenstein
oh man gina haspel uh paul nakasoni at
nsa i mean the whole like there was just
a big crew of people that just didn't
yeah gina haspel has i mean oh my god i
mean there's so many stories that are
absolutely crazy about her yeah uh
i can't even say like what she's accused
of can i tell you what the former
director of the cia was doing when
russia gave broke on british
shores with uh christopher steele
secretly meeting with all the people in
england
gina haspel was leading up our
intelligence apparatus in the kingdom
united wow
huh so she would know more than you
would think she would she would be the
one no one got that question in her eyes
to to understand this entire situation
and make the right shots to make the
right cause for it and uh
nope i mean so bigger than watergate
oh yeah 100 but the watergate broke the
watergate the media was able to actually
have humility there was indictments yeah
they were able to look at themselves and
be like hey we lied this wasn't true
this is the actual truth here based on
the documents but back then you still
had a media
the political operatives learned like we
got to control the media before we pull
something like this off again well you
guys are the pros what do you think do
you think we get to a position where the
media is not all of it most of it issues
a correction or of course no way
so so look here's what's happening with
the media
brian stelter for instance do you think
he's gonna report on any of this stuff
no he's not of course he's not is he is
he the guy that doesn't wear shorts on
tv or is that somebody that's him
there's a photo of him uh
showing his full view
with short shorts
these are these are coming by the way
we're not doing that we're all close
yeah we are all close
these are companies that know their
ratings are in the gutter and they know
that if they were actually going to do
news they'd have to report the truth now
but then they would lose money
so
it's a crazy thing when you build your
i'll put it this way
obviously you know we have our
perspective but i think our perspective
here is really based on
news reports that we can legitimate we
can we can verify to the best of our
abilities that means i do use cnn very
often i got cnn articles pulled up right
now we didn't use them but when i can
verify it i want to use those sources
100 the problem with a lot of these
sources cnn.com is actually not that bad
foxnews.com is pretty good their cable
pundits are where you'll get the opinion
stuff and the stuff that's kind of
broken fox news tucker carlson does a
good job
i'm not a big fan of ingram and hannity
but they're all right
msnbc is complete trash cnn is complete
trash
and they've built their business around
trump sucks right yeah so they cannot
come out and say good things about trump
ever for any reason because when when
when you dedicate your entire lineup to
this is why trump is bad
here's what happens cnn used to have
regular viewers i used to have cnn
running 24 7 while i'm working this is
legit until i think it was like three or
three or four years ago when all of a
sudden i realized that they stopped
talking about news and we're only
talking about trump i turned it off and
put on fox fox was talking about hong
kong and iran and stuff like that
i left
cnn knows i left they know other
moderate individuals like me who want
the news left they know their only
viewers now are the fervent cult members
if they now try and course correct
they'll lose everyone because they're
not getting me back so they decide to
stay the course
we we built up this show for the most
part i'm
kind of pissing off everybody
you seem to be doing okay but it's
because i think most people who watch
this show like they disagree with me all
the time and tell me i'm wrong but it's
like as we're trying our best to be
factual and consistent and honest about
what's going on
so
hardcore trump supporters are mad at me
obviously antifa people don't like me
the trump supporters got really mad at
me because right after the election i
said trump lost
and the left is now claiming that i've
claimed trump won when i never did and
the rights mad at me or i shouldn't say
they're right but like trump supporters
like his hardcore advocates are mad at
me for saying he did lose it's like a
weird space to be in but i feel like as
long as we just try and pull up the
facts and fact check them to the best of
our abilities then the people who are
going to watch are those who actually
care about being right
and not political tribalism truth cnn
however is trapped
you know so we're at a point where i can
come out and say hey you know that thing
right-wing person said that's wrong and
they'll be like well you know that's tim
cnn if they come out and say we were
wrong about trump they'll get roasted
they'll get annihilated so they they're
trapped forever no more viewership yep
that's it that's where they are forever
that's terrible thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you